for honor was first announced in 2015
and is scheduled to be released in 2017.
we recently got our grubby hands on the
alpha version and have unearthed
seven reasons to be excited about for
honor
first a quick note to my mum mother it
is not a spelling mistake
honor is spelt without a u literally
everywhere except england right now
that's cleared up on with the gameplay
remember being a kid and arguing about
who would win a fight between that guy
from onimusha one of the lost vikings
and sir lancelot
well now you can see first hand knights
vikings and my personal favorite samurai
meet head to head to head and as you
would expect it's bloody as hell
the demeanor the weapon choice the skill
set the aesthetic of each character is
unique to each class
meaning when you wield a sword as a
samurai it looks the part and you feel
damn important and speaking of blood
executions executions
executions you will have the opportunity
to slay your enemies with a brutal final
blow
preventing them from being healed by
another teammate there are some mesmeric
final impacts
but the greatest of all is from the
samurai who are more than happy to
behead anyone that stands in front of
them
get up from that darling if you're the
one receiving the blade to the back of
the head then use the countdown timer
well
by switching to tactical view and
checking where you should next attack on
the battlefield
in real time you can view any area of
the fight and find out which one of your
team requires support or maybe spot a
hull in the opposition's defense
let's look at the fighting mechanics as
they shake up the typical one button
defense used by assassin's creed or the
arkham series
in for honor you are given visual cues
to help determine where to defend
you can block in three ways left right
or forward
when you are blocking left your
character moves into that position which
allows you to predict the attack
patterns of your enemy
but worse still they can predict yours
but you also need to be careful because
it's possible to fake an attack
too if you are absolutely getting
pummeled on the battlefield
you can adopt a more defensive approach
which could give your teammates chance
to get to your position
that might sound a little boring but by
waiting an extra five seconds
could be the difference between being
brutally murdered or having a two-on-one
scenario
the best swordsman has no chance against
two warriors
oh there's a story to unearth too
basically after fighting each other for
a thousand years
the vikings samurai and knights are
about to broke a piece
but arrow shooting bad lady apollyon
decides she likes war and wants it to
continue
a perfectly ridiculous storyline for a
perfectly ridiculous game
bravo finally game types in addition to
the campaign we have access to five
different game types to battle through
dominion mode is essentially conquest or
domination in battlefield and has four
players and their minions fight another
four players and their minions
their task is to hold three combat zones
inspirationally titled
a b and c it's also skirmish which is
essentially the same as this but without
the capture points
brawl is a two on two versus mod in
which speed plays a key part
allowing you to team up against one
hapless opponent
duel is a straight-up one-on-one affair
where your defensive skills will be
tested
and finally elimination which is a 4 and
4 death fest
where everyone has a single life so
that's seven reasons to be excited about
for honor
will you be picking this game up and
more importantly who do you think would
win in a fight between knights
samurai and vikings please do me a favor
and massage my ego by pressing that
subscribe
button i'm adam from psg i'll see you
next time